ça c'est londres une heure c'est tout ce
qu'il a fallu pour conduire l'humanité
au bord de l'extinction
les peuples se sont relevés une nouvelle
ère est née celle des sites et
prédatrice la loi
du plus rapide
bye bye aux vans times ça c'est pour ma
mère
bah
arrêtée là
demandez lui pourquoi il a tué ma mère
dommage que tu entendu cela
hester chaud elle fera tout ce qu'elle
peut pour me tue
sauf si vous la tuer avant retrouver
ça faisait longtemps que je cherchais ma
mère avait fait une découverte
dangereuse elle avait peur de
valentine's de ce qu'ils en feraient
l'homme qui contrôle ceux ci contrôlent
monde elle m'a dit que tu pouvait
l'arrêter
parme est capable d'anéantir la plus
grande cité en un clin d'oeil
il faut la neutraliser
rien ne peut lui résister
nous devons arrêter londres avant
qu'elle nous détruisent
tu es sûr que tu veux y aller une fois
entré on ne pourra plus reculés il le
faut
moi
[Musique]